six one seven eight three zero 47 50 a
lot of people holding today let's see
who is calling in from the 909 area code
caller from 909 and hopefully that weird
garbled thing that's going on with the
calls will will resolve who's there at
909 hi David this is Lewis Lewis go
ahead hi David yeah so uh big fan i
watch you secular talk and other left
left-wing media sources although I will
say that I'm a pretty hard hard right
conservative so I try to watch everyone
from from you to Ben Shapiro so that way
I get a more well-rounded view having
said that my question is why he doesn't
there seem to be more of a nuanced view
of some supporters or those in their
life because like myself I'm for
integration but I'm for the border wall
I'm for cousins but I'm also for
background tracks and so that I'm just
giving an example at you and it just
seems that that the left generally tries
to bring up the worst argument out of us
make us look like Alex Jones words so I
just open why is it that they that they
seem to try the trip is like the radical
guys and when a lot of us are just guys
that have different opinions but we're
not that crazy
so I I don't know that I fully
understand you're saying that you
believe that Trump supporters are being
caricatured as more extreme than they
actually are
yeah okay well I think that just because
there are less extreme views doesn't
mean that the predominant point of view
of any particular group might be more
extreme than than you right I mean it's
just so you don't have those views but
there's certainly a benefit to sort of
kowtow into those extreme views it's
what got Trump elected right so I think
I guess I'm just not sure what what the
point would be yeah there are less so
let me let me put it a different way
what would it have taken for you to vote
for Hillary Clinton to be honest I don't
think anything but
again I didn't over Trump I thought that
they were both very horrible choices and
it was it was you know picture poison
so vote yeah no I did it but I will say
that I kind of gone on I have come to
support him the only thing is that I
don't support everything he says or does
but it seems that you if you call
yourself a trump supporter it's like you
know me all or nothing and I think
that's unfair to those like yeah well
what what made you become a supporter of
Trump like what has he done during his
presidency that that you now support him
but didn't before first I would say
specifically his economic policy giving
tax cuts lowering the tax corporation
the tax attackers on the corporations
like that so that's a lot of stuff there
so what in what way is he not
apologizing for America in ways that
others have like what would be an
example of apologizing for America I
would say going around the world and
saying that the United States is going
to protect the borders their people but
they want to also help others by putting
America first and I felt like Obama when
he was president really but you can kind
of see the negative light and seem to
apologize for our actions like what what
actions didn't get Obama but I'm sorry
saying what what actions was Obama
apologizing for that Trump won't
apologize for
I think the aggressive foreign policy
the media never back and and go and you
know it's going around the world
policeman well but hold on a second
Trump specifically said that the
decision to go into Iraq was the worst
decision ever made that was way more of
an apology than I ever heard from
President Obama he straight-up said it
was the worst
three decision ever made it so but you
said Trump's not doing my Trump is doing
that he did exactly that Trump also said
that Hillary was going to get us into
all sorts of wars and he and he wouldn't
that that's exactly that's literally
what you just said Obama was doing and
you like that Trump isn't doing Trump
has done that did you see any of that
stuff yeah and I'll be the first isn't
that I don't agree with with everything
no but here's what I'm trying to
understand Louis and this is where I
really get very very confused and sort
of dismayed at where we are one of the
things you said that has made you go
from not a trump supporter to a trump
supporter is that he doesn't apologize
for the u.s. his actions I asked for
some examples and you said well like
Obama would go around apologizing for
the invasion of Iraq and for military
action in other countries I don't know
that I ever heard him do that but that's
exactly what Trump ran on he ran on Iraq
was a disaster but that's the exact
opposite of what you said do you see how
that's competing no III do I didn't say
that we shouldn't have invaded Iraq oh
so you agree with them so what a second
Louis so you started by saying you think
that Trump doesn't apologize like Obama
did for going into Iraq but actually
Trump has apologized for that in a sense
he's called they're a huge mistake and
you're saying you agree with the apology
so how is that now something that has
made you support Trump but do you see
how this is incoherent no because you're
taking one example I this rifle I feel
like you're taking one example than I'm
saying and then you're applying it to
everything that I that I say for Trump
or no I'm only taking the example you
cited and applying it to what you're
saying Louis I would love to go through
the others but there's plenty for five
people holding I appreciate the call I'm
a little confused by the call but I
really do appreciate hearing from you
it's it's interesting to get this
insight